creo que es interesante lo rápido que
puede cambiar tu opinión sobre alguien
en cuanto a su personalidad Fue genial
conocer gente y luego ver dónde se
encontraban en la alineación porque
tenía otra suposiciones hechas sobre
dónde pensaba que deberían estar eso fue
casi una prueba de la realidad
Mi nombre es Connor tengo 21 años soy de
Chicago Illinois
Hola soy Claire tengo 22 años soy de
California y estoy recién graduada de la
universidad Hola soy Sierra tengo 22
años soy de Massachusetts pero vivo en
Los Ángeles y soy redactora de
contenidos soy Gravity Tengo 23 años Soy
ingeniero y soy de Los Ángeles Mi nombre
es Valentino
adorable y tengo 19 años soy de Los
Ángeles soy estudiante de enfermería y
soy influencer en las redes sociales
estás en el universo Cuál era la carrera
de cada uno cine bien psicología oyó en
inglés y guionista astrofísica
así que eres inteligente el nombre de
Gravity empieza a tener sentido
y bueno qué les gusta hacer para
divertirse me gusta viajar me gusta leer
comer helado me gusta salir con mis
perros tengo dos acerca Jack sembrar
hacer parrilla vegetariana no soy
vegetariano
me gusta el cine y la fotografía salir
con mis amigos y grabar vídeos para
YouTube Sí aquí estás
tiene sentido me gusta estar en mi casa
pero mi principal afición es el cosplay
bien
me gusta ver muchas películas ya sea con
amigos o solo
ahora me siento mal
en Qué grupos estaban en la universidad
teatro
estabas entre bastidores o actuabas no
actúe varias veces pero el último lo
dirigí y tú Gravity pasaba mucho tiempo
en la biblioteca con el personal ese
tipo de cosas me educaron en casa tomé
clases en el colegio comunitario durante
el primer y el último año fui una
especie de estudiante de colegio
comunitario bien qué hicieron para su
último cumpleaños Un par de amigos y yo
fuimos sombrar y tomamos un par de
tragos yo hice lo mismo porque
así que mis dos últimos cumpleaños no
fueron como quería que te gusta me
gustaría ir a hacer cosas actividades y
ustedes
solo me gusta estar fuera me gusta estar
junto al mar viajar por carretera siento
que este es mi momento casi todos los
cumpleaños que he tenido han sido buenos
Mi último cumpleaños a los 19 fui a
Nueva York con mi hermana durante un par
de días y luego regresé a un concierto
con mi mejor amigo cuál concierto
Dime algo eres quien le pida a la gente
que salga o eres a quien invitan a todos
lados creo que es algo mutuo entre mis
amigos y yo es como vamos a salir al
tener solo un amigo cercano siempre doy
muchas ideas y luego digo bien Me dices
cuando quieres hacer esto porque quiero
hacer esto Ahora yo les pregunto a mis
amigos pero solo mis amigos más cercanos
con los demás nunca sé si debo
preguntarles o si me preguntaran
me encanta iniciar las cosas siempre les
pregunto a mis amigos quieren ir a un
restaurante O quieres ir a otro sitio
siempre están ellos siempre lo están lo
que me hace sentir que no estoy haciendo
suficiente eres perfecto
sientes que tienes una amplia gama de
amigos a los que les pediría salir sí sí
diría que es un grupo grande bien siento
que aprendo mucho y nada al mismo tiempo
[Risas]
digamos Cuál es la primera impresión que
tuvo cada uno bien Connor eres un Enigma
Por tu forma de hablar eres más
extrovertido de lo que pensaba Haces
muchas cosas parece que te gusta estar
con la gente creo que estarías mejor en
el medio solo por el hecho de que no
hablas tanto como el resto parece que
haces actividades con la gente pero
también me parece que tal vez no está
haciendo del todo honesto creo que diré
que de este grupo probablemente estás en
el cuarto lugar sí estamos bien de
acuerdo ahora es tu turno para estar en
el filo
a medida que avanzaba el día estabas a
cargo de la conversación la estabas
haciendo avanzar Yo diría que estás en
el uno dos uno dos o bien Ustedes son
los dos primeros
en términos de Todos creen que somos los
dos primeros
Alguien podría bien el resto de los
puestos está bien yo me moveré uno hacia
abajo eso crees aquí porque Noté que la
conversación suele empezar por ti y
luego por ti y pasar por esta línea de
vuelta a mí creo que debería estar al
final crees que tú hicieras deberían
cambiar creo que estoy en el cuarto
quinto no sé pero me parece bien cambiar
bien bien No no es que no quiera que
seas menos extrovertida que Connor Es
que creo que sí Cóndor dice la verdad él
sale con sus amigos
lo haría en comparación con alguien
introvertido pero yo diría que las
personas extrovertidas no les gusta
salir de fiesta a Connor le podría
gustar salir con sus amigos pero tal vez
por poco tiempo creo que si me divierto
en una fiesta Me quedaría más tiempo
pero nunca sería el que baila en el
centro de la pista porque no quiero
llamar la atención quiero divertirme
pero no quiero atención bien Pueden
decir las primeras impresiones para que
pueda
primeras impresiones sobre ti bien Pensé
que estarías más abajo porque entraste
tan tranquila y yo estaba como tal vez
ella es introvertida pero tiene un muy
buen estilo y eso me confunde un poco
creo que después de hablar contigo estás
en el lugar correcto no tengo duda de
eso no sé eras un Enigma pero parece que
sabes que estás en el lado más
extrovertido
siento que eres muy segura de ti misma
lo sabes lo sabes siento que deberías
estar más arriba en lo personal es que
deberíamos cambiar sí bien quieres
cambiar bien bien Sí porque dijiste que
te gusta el aire libre y usas el kayak
es hacer kayak individual o no tengo un
kayak tanmen dos personas Allí tienes
amigos
tienes amigos Tal vez crees que deberían
No lo sé yo creo que deberíamos cambiar
Yo también estaba pensando en eso pero
no quería Sí sí sí me equivoqué No es
que no creía que seas más extrovertida
también
es que Es evidente que eres extrovertido
si es algo evidentemente
que es más obvio sí la primera impresión
que se nota que eres más extrovertido
pero ese no es mi caso no Así es verdad
Seguro bien sí Entonces estamos
conformes con esta alineación
no estoy segura creo que debe ir más
arriba
no sé ahora siento que lo pienso
demasiado creo que están en el lugar que
están seguro sientes que ese es tu lugar
sí bien
te sientes bien dónde estás sí
te sientes bien dónde estás y tú te
sientes
mi ego me dice que debo ser el número
uno pero no no creo que sea el número
uno
Entonces quieres cambiar tú quieres
cambiar Quieres jugar piedra
resolverlo hagamoslo
estoy cómodo en esta posición aquí vaya
no me importa también
cambiamos
bien estamos bien ahora está bien
[Música]
en primer lugar cambiaremos a Gravity
con Claire
ahora que Connor cambie con Claire
y que cierra cambie con Claire
unos mentiste
Así que era desde el más introvertido al
más extrovertido
Entonces nos metiste no
Deseo saber mejor que está pasando
no esperaba que Claire fuera la más
introvertida porque era ella quien
guiaba las conversaciones ella aparecía
extrovertida mi tipo de personalidad de
mayor breaks es
ntp e ntj yo nfj yo y nfj y yo y en fp
no mentí parezco muy extrovertida soy
capaz de mantener una conversación y
hablar con la gente pero por dentro me
canso mi ansiedad me frena debido a
eventos pasados en mi vida en la
universidad experimenté una relación
Abusiva que me afectó mucho y aumentó mi
ansiedad sufría de ataques de pánico y
ahora tengo miedo de ir a ciertos
lugares solo me gusta hacer ciertas
cosas creo que tuvo un impacto en la
forma en que hago todo y pero estoy
aprendiendo a llegar a un acuerdo con lo
que soy ahora esto no era lo que
esperaba
me visto colorida para expresarme mejor
esa es una buena razón por la que mucha
gente piensa que soy extrovertida y que
me gusta estar fuera y salir pero esto
es Solo otra forma de comunicación
cuando a veces es difícil para mí
hacerlo cuando por primera vez Pensé que
ibas a estar arriba Supongo que y va a
sonar muy cursi pero no puedes juzgar un
libro por su portada pero es
literalmente lo que hicimos aquí y luego
resultó ser diferente les gusta
distraerse con gente o solos tardo mucho
en distraerme Dejémoslo así tengo esta
respuesta me gusta ponerme mis
pantalones más cómodos mis calcetines y
me gusta comer palomitas de queso y ver
una película o leer un libro Eso es lo
que me gusta hacer